what's what's next kevin what's next for
you man what's what's next on the
horizon
you want me to be honest with you i
don't know what i'm doing
i'm just i don't know what i'm doing but
i know i'm on the right path
i tell my wife that all the time because
my wife used my wife to listen so um
sometimes we have um we're we're
enterprise now you know now i'm
corporate guys so every now and then we
have people that say mike
i want to invest in you and do this and
i and what do you want to do and i would
say
if someone has a billion dollars they
say hey mike here what do you want to do
i would say i don't know nothing nothing
right
and my wife gets back and i say whatever
i want it just comes to me i don't
go out and get it it comes to me store
my life you know what man
that's the story do you understand what
i'm saying no
listen it comes to me whatever i want i
get it yeah
i don't want to talk about it
whatever that's crazy yeah but i also
think too sometimes mike is you probably
already imagined
in your head you just don't play like
the normal human no that's a normal
person probably would so this is what i
do now
when it comes to me i give it right to
my wife my wife knows what to do with
the money see i don't i feel
uncomfortable taking money and stuff
but then one of my friends said if you
don't take money from a friend or take
favors from a friend and you're not
really a friend so i have to take money
to make this guy believe i'm just it's
just i don't like that soul stuff
yeah it's hard for me to accept to
accept things from people because
in my mind i'm always what's going to
come behind this
i just feel like i feel emotional like
it's a pride thing with me
like i don't the worst thing i can do is
exit somebody for something
yeah even if i really need help i gotta
really swallow my pride and ask for help
no but i think it's important what mike
said yeah yeah i think i think it's like
if you can't accept from a friend then
you're really not a friend
that hurt me that i i wanted to have a
way probably i wanted to use prior to
when my friend said how could you be my
friend if you want to accept
a friend a friend's deed then i said
well you're right
yeah it's almost like this like true
humbleness
it's not somebody that boasts about his
success or he's got you know gold
you know what i'm saying like a true
humbleness is somebody that asked for
help dude
like you know what i'm saying that true
humbleness is somebody that's that's
that's honest would you would you say
mike like that's listen right
i'm weak man i need help or you know
what i'm saying i don't look at that
like humble
no i'm not that ain't humble you just a
[ __ ] that need help
i look at humble as when you can be a
legend and you grading
like when rudyard kipling said in that
poem if if you could walk amongst kings
but not lose the communist touch then
you would be a man my son
i don't think it's important seriously
that's that's what i look at as being
humble like
you know i go walk on water right now
but a hater will probably say it's only
because i can't swim
but i'm super humble i try cause all i
can do is try my best
so that's what i look at is being humble
like not bragging and boasting on myself
yeah
i'm humble i carry myself in humility
that's why i don't have to have
50 bodyguards because i know how to
stand and greet a man whenever he walk
in the room
well i give most of my money to cherry
cause i just can't be humble i just
gotta talk some [ __ ]
yeah we gotta turn up gotta talk about
charity and
i'm entertaining people i don't really
mean this [ __ ] yeah you gotta turn up
some
time though but when you do mike you
gotta turn those there's a hundred
thousand tickets right
you gotta turn up sometimes